[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer et la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au menu de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ce 14 février
c'est un moyen de transport innovant à
50 ans en Yvelines des capsules
électriques sur rail urban loop vont
circuler à l'île de loisirs cette
expérimentation se déroulera pendant les
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 avant un
déploiement à plus grand déchet l'Urban
loop a été présenté il y a quelques
jours au Forum de lait à Paris nous en
parlons avec Jean-Baptiste à Monique
vice-président de l'agglomération
et des habitants piochent à la main pour
bâtir un projet de leur vie la mort pas
une microforêt urbaine va pousser dans
le quartier de la joie de l'agiot dans
les prochaines années et 1900 arbres et
arbustes au Square de l'Estérel ont lieu
et place d'une ancienne station-service
et de nombreux morts passés en participé
au lancement du projet
et puis retour sur cet événement qui
arramblé les passionnés de breakdance à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse dimanche le Red
Bull BBC One mettait tout prise les
meilleurs big girls et bboys de France
pour une place en finale nationale
l'occasion pour la discipline olympique
de faire le plein d'engouement à un peu
plus d'un an de Paris 2024 et ce sera
tout à l'heure dans la partie culture où
l'on présentera également un festival
qui va démarrer ce soir c'est au Mureaux
le festival et du film francophone pour
la jeunesse la deuxième édition s'ouvre
ce soir donc au cinéma Frédéric Dard et
c'est jusqu'au 21 février dans un
instant également les informations du
jour et puis des invités qui sont avec
moi mon plateau Jean-Baptiste à Monique
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
vice-président donc de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines en charge et
des transports aînés mobilité durable on
va parler avec vous dans un instant de
ce projet
urban loop qui commence à faire son
chemin du côté de l'agglomération
également en face de vous il y a Nicolas
korobenic bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur régional d'Île-de-France
Île-de-France de l'association
Prévention Routière alors avec vous on
va parler justement de sécurité routière
il y a les derniers chiffres de l'année
2022 qui ont été révélés il y a il y a
deux semaines avec notamment une hausse
du point de vue de la mortalité des
cyclistes on en parlera tout à l'heure
en quelques mots l'association
Prévention Routière c'est quoi c'est une
vieille association qui fait de la
sensibilisation sur le risque routier
depuis maintenant plus de 70 ans on
sensibilise des Français de la
maternelle au seniors avec différents
outils de sensibilisation et on
accompagne les Français sur les enfants
dans leur l'évolution de leur mobilité
on parlera de tout ça de tous ces sujets
tout à l'heure et le dernier invité
c'est Geoffrey Meyer bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes avocat au Barreau de
Versailles également si un secrétaire de
la Conférence du stage on va parler avec
vous de la situation des avocats alors
que le ministre de la Justice Éric
Dupond-Moretti a présenté en janvier son
plan d'action issu des états généraux de
la justice en avant goût en quelques
mots quel est le moral donc aujourd'hui
pour les avocats il est toujours très
contrasté être avocat c'est c'est un
métier c'est un métier compliqué on est
toujours plein d'espoir parce qu'on se
doit de l'être pour accompagner ou plus
juste les justiciables dont on a la
charge des intérêts mais on fait face
aussi à un certain nombre de difficultés
et je pense qu'on évoquera ça dans votre
émission on va développer ces sujets
tout à l'heure et puis comme chaque
mardi des rendez-vous vous avez
l'habitude de retrouver dans le 7 8 les
insolites de Véronique pour connaître
les informations qui vous ont peut-être
échappé dans le département des Yvelines
et puis l'astuce du chef pour briller
chez vous en cuisine et ce soir c'est le
ris de veau de de maudissako qui est
passé au crible c'est le chef du
restaurant Les Quatre Saisons à
Versailles ça vous donne fin en plateau
avant de passer à table peut-être c'est
un super repas pour la Saint-Valentin
c'est en tout cas voilà c'est ça pour ce
genre effectivement de la Saint-Valentin
il faudra un peu patienter pour avoir la
recette ce sera tout à l'heure enfin
d'émission alors avant de dérouler ce
programme on va jeter tout de suite un
coup d'oeil aux prévisions météo de
demain
il y aura un ciel voilé sur toute la
journée de mercredi avec même du
brouillard annoncé le matin côté
température il fera 1 degré à
Mantes-la-Jolie 2 degrés dans le centre
est sud du département et dans
l'après-midi même condition mais un
thermomètre qui a grimpe il fera et 10
degrés à Rambouillet Versailles 11
degrés à Houdan et Mantes-la-Jolie ce
mercredi 15 février c'est la Saint
Claude le point à présent sur
l'actualité du jour de ce mardi 14
février dans les Yvelines c'est avec
Mathilde Franco
si vous avez essayé de prendre
rendez-vous chez votre médecin
aujourd'hui vous avez peut-être eu
encore plus de mal que d'habitude la
majorité des cabinets étaient fermés
pour cause de grève les généralistes
mais aussi les soignants hospitaliers
dénoncent une nouvelle fois le manque de
considération pour leur secteur environ
15000 médecins se sont mobilisés en
France
depuis le 9 février la région
Île-de-France subit un épisode important
de pollution de l'air les basses
températures et les vents faibles ne
favorisent pas la bonne dispersion des
particules de CO2 dans notre département
c'est principalement le Nord et l'Est
des Yvelines qui sont impactés la
situation devrait revenir à la normale
dans les prochains jours il n'était pas
présent pour accueillir le ministre des
Transports Clément Beaune la Présidente
de la Région
Île-de-France la mère de Paris et les
présidents des départements des Yvelines
et des Hauts-de-Seine ont tous boycoté
la visite du ministre concernant le
chantier du RER EOL il dénonce le manque
de financement de la part du
gouvernement nous n'avons à ce jour pas
le premier euro pour faire fonctionner
les trains qui relieront en 2024
Saint-Lazare et la défense le bus santé
femme revient les 16 et 17 février à
plaisir le jeudi il sera sur l'esplanade
du centre commercial du valibout et le
vendredi sur le parking du centre
commercial Brigitte l'objectif rompre
l'isolement des femmes et leur donner
accès à des conseils santé et juridiques
et aujourd'hui nous sommes le 14 février
c'est le jour de la Saint Valentin vous
avez peut-être déjà acheté des fleurs ou
un cadeau pour votre partenaire en
France certains commerçants triple leur
chiffre d'affaires beaucoup d'hommes
beaucoup d'amoureux tout va bien c'est
une fête qui marche bien et avec tout
âge ça va vraiment des plus jeunes tout
le monde tout le monde fait le 14
février c'est quand même un jour qui est
très intéressant pour nous caviste ce
jour-là qu'on propose plusieurs types de
produits notamment les champagnes
champagne rosé qui passe très très bien
mais alors pourquoi faites ton amour ce
jour-là il s'agirait en fait d'une fête
païenne célébrée par les Romains durant
le mois de février ces derniers célébrer
les dieux de la fécondité et du mariage
de 1000 ans plus tard c'est resté la
fête des amoureux
voilà pour ces informations et si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes témoin
d'une information d'une actualité à qui
vous fait réagir et n'hésitez pas à le
dire sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news en tout cas
une actualité qui devrait intéresser nos
téléspectateurs la presse nationale
s'est emparée du sujet et je le disais
en début d'émission c'est ce moyen de
transport innovant à 50 ans en Yvelines
des capsules électriques sur rail Nobel
urban loop qui vont circuler à l'île de
loisir cette expérimentation se
déroulera pendant les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 et même juste avant
Jean-Baptiste amonic était avec nous en
plateau pour en parler je rappelle que
vous êtes vice-président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines en
charge des transports et de la mobilité
et des mobilités durables et donc ce
moyen de transport innovant été présenté
la semaine dernière c'était lors du
Forum ait à Paris pour agence de
l'innovation pour les pour les
transports il y avait un intérêt autour
de cette urban loop c'est un peu le la
star peut-être de ce forum oui ça a été
une des attractions effectivement de ce
forum on a eu l'occasion avec les
équipes de Jean-Philippe Mangeot qui
porte le projet urbal loop ils sont
lancé un initialement des ingénieurs
mais ils sont appuyés aussi sur
l'université ils ont travaillé avec le
CNRS ils sont sérieux ils sont solides
on a présenté cette nouvelle technologie
au Forum de l'IAT à la Cité des Sciences
on a eu l'occasion de l'exposer à Madame
Idrac et au ministre Clément bonne le
ministre des Transports qui était là
aussi puis surtout c'était un peu un
retour aux sources pour eux puisque
l'année dernière ils ont été lauréats du
plan d'investissement pour l'avenir du
gouvernement donc dans le cadre de
France 2030 ce qui a vraiment permis de
leur mettre le pied à l'étrier et à
l'occasion de ce forum on récompensait
en tout cas le gouvernement récompensé
de nouveaux lauréat donc je dirais pas
curban look boucle la boucle mais en
tout cas ils sont bien partis et on va
les accueillir avec plaisir en 2024 à
l'occasion des Jeux Olympiques on a vu
quelques images un Power ce à quoi
ressemble cette urbanoop ça fonctionne
comment concrètement urban loop alors on
parlait tout à l'heure dans votre sujet
de la pollution de l'air clairement là
on a un transport une nouvelle mobilité
innovante durable qui coche la case de
décarbonée les transports qui je le
rappelle sont le premier secteur
émetteur de CO2 et de particules fines
en France et en Europe très peu
consommateurs très peu consommateurs
très peu consommateurs en termes
d'énergie évidemment c'est un transport
électrique qui s'auto suffit c'est un
transport qui est très peu consommateur
aussi en emprise foncière puisque vous
l'avez dit c'est sur rail mais toutes
les installations sont réversibles c'est
un transport qui au sol et est très
léger et puis il a surtout l'avantage
d'être très rapide c'est à dire que il a
été
homologué et avec le record de vitesse
mondial sur ce type de technologie et
aujourd'hui il peut aller jusqu'à 60
km/h nous sur Saint-Quentin sur la
portion et sur le démonstrateur qu'on
aura sur la base de loisirs en 2024 il
sera plutôt autour de 30 40 km/h
d'accord mais il est tout à fait
concurrentiel aujourd'hui je rappelle
que c'est un démonstrateur c'est à dire
que nous le surexpérimenter sur une
expérience qu'on a l'habitude de le
faire sur 50 ans en Yvelines on l'a fait
avec les trottinettes électriques ça
c'est très bien passé donc aujourd'hui
on a périmé le service on l'a fait aussi
avec la navette Navia navette autonome
ça s'est bien passé mais pour le coup
pour des raisons sur lesquelles je
reviendrai pas ce soir mais on a décidé
de pas continuer sur cette
expérimentation dont la page généralisée
en tout cas donc là on est vraiment sur
un démonstrateur je rappelle que c'est
une technologie française que elle est
massivement soutenue par l'ensemble des
acteurs puisque je parlais de l'Etat
soutenu financièrement
France 2030 c'est à dire que c'est 50%
des financements qui sont alloués par
l'État à urban loop ce qui veut dire que
le reste à charge pour l'agglomération
est d'à peu près 750 000 euros sur un
transport innovant comme celui-ci c'est
c'est tout à fait raisonnable donc
expérimentation avant peut-être un
déploiement à plus grande il y a
notamment la ville de Nancy qui est sur
le coup peut-être aussi à 50 ans en
Yvelines si l'expérimentation fonctionne
bien ou
un démonstrateur pour le moment on est
sur un démonstrateur nous on croit
beaucoup en cette technologie on a
l'occasion avec les Jeux Olympiques
d'avoir tous les projecteurs qui seront
arrivés sur 50 ans en Yvelines avec nos
quatre sites olympiques donc d'avoir ce
démonstrateur qui en plus sera un
intérêt sur cette séquence là puisqu'il
viendra des servir la Fan Zone il
viendra aussi connecter le BMX avec avec
les pistes de vélo à cet endroit là
voilà territoire d'innovation encore une
fois sur Saint-Quentin donc nous on est
plutôt fiers de pouvoir porter cette
nouvelle technologie qui est encore une
fois est durable et propre sont des
capsules autonomes qui permettront de
faire de transporter plus de 240
personnes à l'heure combien de personnes
dans une capsule une seule
personne son vélo aussi exactement
puisqu'on a souhaité qu'elle puisse être
un petit peu on va dire modulable en
tout cas il y a la possibilité d'avoir
un vélo et puis si finalement prendre le
vélo pour aller voir le vélo en termes
d'épreuve olympique il quelque chose de
cohérent là-dedans donc voilà on a on va
dire que c'était un peu une course et
c'est toujours une course de haie donc
on saute on saute les haies étape par
étape on a réussi à avoir cette
délégation de compétences
d'Île-de-France mobilité pour pouvoir
porter l'expérimentation ce qui est une
véritable marque de confiance la
deuxième étape c'était de créer le
consortium puisque c'est urban loop
Saint-Quentin avec Keolis qui en aura à
sa charge d'exploitation du service et
puis là très récemment en bureau
communautaire pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière on a adopté la
convention de financement avec l'ADEME
qui est donc l'organisme de l'État qui
finance à hauteur de 50% dans le cadre
du Plan fonce 2030 est-ce que demain on
aura d'autres est-ce que urban loop a
vocation à s'installer sur Saint-Quentin
demain c'est encore beaucoup trop tôt
pour le dire en tout cas moi je je tire
mon chapeau à Urbano et à l'ensemble des
équipes parce qu'ils ont réussi vraiment
à concocter quelque chose qui est
vraiment très performant très innovant
et moi j'ai nul doute que ça fonctionne
donc en tout cas le démonstrateur est
attendu de pied ferme sur l'île de
loisirs cette réaction avec nos autres
invités si on peut remontrer les images
le fait de monter dans une navette alors
qui une capsule
dans ce genre de capsule moi j'ai été
mon déjà fait l'expérimentation du
véhicule autonome quand il était entre
sur Paris sur donc oui je serai prêt à
monter dans ce dans ce genre de capsule
je trouve la technologie absolument
remarquable et je serai ravi de
l'essayer si jamais l'occasion on était
donnée alors vous avez parlé des
différents financements subventions
notamment de l'État alors j'avais lu
deux chiffres dans la presse un coup
d'1,6 millions d'euros la plus récemment
750 000 euros on est autour de quel en
fait vous avez raison c'est 1,6 mais si
vous divisez par deux c'est-à-dire qu'à
partir du moment où l'État prend 50 %
c'est-à-dire que le reste à charge pour
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et de 750
globalement on est à peu près dans les
dans les mêmes ordres de grandeur donc
est-ce que ça ça fait changer d'avis les
élus d'opposition de 50 ans et demi qui
était contre le projet soldat d'un
projet je cite gadget pour la pour
l'agglomération alors ils ont ils sont
ils sont pas opposés là quand on a voté
quand j'ai présenté le financement de la
dame ils sont pas opposés ils sont
abstenus ils ont changé un petit peu de
position
ils mettent ça mais je trouve que c'est
c'est excusez-moi mais je trouve que
c'est une bêtise ils mettent ça en
parallèle avec les mobilités douces en
disant c'est une somme qu'on aurait pu
allouer au vélo par exemple sur
Saint-Quentin alors je rappelle juste
les deux chiffres 750 000 € pour Urban
loop on a adopté un plan de 37 millions
d'euros pour faire un schéma directeur
cyclable qui nous permettra d'avoir 600
km d'itinéraires cyclable sur
l'agglomération donc on peut pas dire
qu'on ne porte pas d'ambition pour le
vélo voilà je pense qu'il en tout cas
ils ont manifesté un point de vue et une
position politique que je comprends et
que j'entends ça n'empêchera pas au
projet d'être adopté et puis de toute
façon on va y aller mais moi je reste
dans le dialogue avec eux j'essaye de
les rassurer je rappelle que
l'itinéraire a été revu et corrigé
justement parce que il est beaucoup plus
performant sur le plan environnemental
aujourd'hui mais ça reste ça reste un
projet je pense qu'il faut qu'on
accueille sur 50 ans divine très
rapidement le calendrier donc c'est à
partir de mai 2024 que l'on pourra
les derniers autorisations parce qu'on a
encore un dialogue avec les services de
l'État en préfecture de la DDT et les
autorisations environnementales tout ça
est un peu long mais début des travaux
septembre de septembre à décembre et
puis à partir de début 2024 on va
pouvoir déployer le service ouais donc
pour ce projet urban loop donc qui verra
le jour à 50 ans en Yvelines et on aura
l'occasion de pouvoir monter dedans au
moment des Jeux Olympiques 2024 à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on le rappelle
un des sites olympiques bien sûr et des
épreuves olympiques qui sont accueillis
sur sur ce territoire en face de vous on
va parler à présent de de sécurité
routière avec Nicolas corobenic je le
disais vous êtes le directeur régional
Île-de-France de l'association
Prévention Routière on parlait tout à
l'heure de cette association et des
actions qui sont déployées on va parler
aussi un de ces derniers chiffres de la
sécurité routière qui ont été révélés il
y a deux semaines alors déjà une
première tendance à vendre parler de
l'augmentation de la mort des des
cyclistes en 2022 si on prend l'année de
référence ce qui est 2019 il y a une
augmentation en 2022 en 2022 pardon d'un
point de vue global sur la mortalité on
est plutôt sur des des statistiques
stables en France on parle d'une
augmentation seulement de 0,5% 3260
décès en 2022 est-ce qu'on Île-de-France
on est sur la même tendance et on est
sur la même tendance en Île-de-France et
3260 décès en France c'est il y a une
augmentation par rapport à 2019 que
l'année de référence et il y avait un
engagement du gouvernement de d'amener
le nombre de morts en 2020 à
2000 personnes sur les routes 2020 c'est
l'année covid et même cette année où on
a été freiné dans nos dans nos
déplacements où il y a eu des périodes
de restriction on n'a pas atteint ce
chiffre de 2000 personnes tuées sur les
routes en France on était autour de 2500
morts voilà donc
on ne compte pas les deux années cogues
en tout cas on les compte mais
même le début 2022 où il y avait des
restrictions encore sur les sur les sur
les déplacements donc cette augmentation
de
0,5%, elle est à corréler avec le début
de l'année 2022 donc ça c'est pour les
chiffres global point de vue des
automobilistes on est plutôt sur une
tendance à la baisse même oui on est sur
une tendance à la baisse sur les sur les
automobilistes et par contre une
tendance à la hausse sur les usagers
vulnérables
usagers vulnérables et on parle
notamment et c'est l'objet de notre
interview de l'augmentation de la
mortalité chez les cyclistes c'est un
phénomène aussi qui s'observe chez les
utilisateurs de trottinettes on aura
l'occasion d'en parler il y a une hausse
de 30% au niveau de la France au niveau
national et pour la deuxième année
consécutive la barre des 200 morts a été
franchi au niveau de la mortalité des
des cyclistes si on regarde les chiffres
au niveau francilien c'est neuf
personnes qui ont perdu la vie en vélo
en 2022 comment on explique cette il y a
de plus en plus d'utilisateurs de vélo
depuis justement le covid 19 peut-être
avec eux aussi cet impact écologique il
y a eu un changement des habitudes des
français sur sur le déplacement et
2020-2021 il y a eu un report de la part
modale et d'augmentation du nombre de
cyclistes nous c'est quelque chose qu'on
a qu'on a identifié tout de suite à la
l'association et on a vu aussi des gens
ressortir des vélos qui étaient mal
entretenus ou qui était ou des personnes
qui n'avaient pas fait de vélo depuis
longtemps
se remettre à faire du vélo peut-être un
manque de vigilance de ces personnes là
en manque il y a un manque de vigilance
il y a une infrastructure qui est en
train de de s'adapter aussi à ce nouveau
mode de déplacement vous l'aviez dit
tout à l'heure il y a un plan de
développement sur Saint-Quentin des de
piste cyclable donc il faut que chacun
trouve sa place dans dans ce dans la
route et sur la et sur la rue pour que
chacun puisse circuler librement selon
le mode de déplacement qu'il a choisi on
a joué à qui c'est Jean-Baptiste
amonique il y a des efforts qui sont
faits par les collectivités en matière
de vélo on parle de plus en plus de ce
projet de RER vélo aussi au niveau qui
est porté par la région qui va se
déployer et qui nous est l'ossature de
notre schéma directeur cyclable je vais
rappeler c'est 37 millions d'euros ça
veut dire que c'est 600 km à terme
d'itinéraire cyclables tout l'enjeu vous
l'avez dit c'est le partage de l'espace
public il faut qu'on arrive à faire en
sorte que les différents acteurs de la
route que les différentes mobilités les
différents modes de déplacement arrivent
à cohabiter entre les chiffres que vous
avez donné je j'ai pas toutes les
explications mais c'est vrai que
proportionnellement j'imagine qu'on doit
avoir un petit peu plus d'accident quand
on a un petit peu plus aussi
d'utilisateurs je trouve que c'est non
plus les accidents attention il faut les
traiter mais c'est une bonne chose de
voir que les comportements évoluent et
que on va de plus en plus vers les modes
actifs et les mobilités douces moi je
vous prends juste un chiffre parce que
je l'ai à l'esprit et que il m'a été
communiqué il y a très peu de temps je
répondais à mes collègues maire de
Saint-Quentin sur le taux
d'accidentologie sur le service de
trottinette de l'agglomération en un an
avec plus d'un million trois de trajet
et 71 utilisateurs on a fait 5 accidents
qui ont concerné et impliqué des
trottinettes tir
c'est rien c'est rien alors ça reste
cinq accidents de trop mais
proportionnellement à ce qu'on peut voir
sur d'autres collectivités ça montre que
tout est aussi à faire d'organisation de
la micromobilité et notamment aussi de
l'usage du vélo donc en tout cas il faut
continuer les efforts sont à faire et je
crois que les infrastructures vous
l'avez dit aussi les infrastructures
sont vraiment la priorité tout à fait
juste avant de parler des trottinettes
si on regarde un peu plus précisément
les chiffres sur les cyclistes c'est
d'ailleurs dans les Yvelines au niveau
francilien qui a eu le plus de morts en
vélo en 2022 3 décès dans le département
et il y a d'ailleurs plus de victimes en
grande couronne que sur Paris il y a eu
un décès à Paris l'an passé ça aussi
comment l'explique c'est que les
utilisateurs à Paris ont peut-être un
peu plus l'habitude d'utiliser le vélo
dans un on va dire dans un environnement
où il y a un peu plus de circulation
aussi
je pense que les les vitesses de
déplacement des véhicules sont Paris
sont plus faibles et donc nous on c'est
quelque chose qu'on qu'on comporte sur
sur les villes on descendre villes
apaisées à 30 km/h des zones de
rencontre c'est c'est des moments où on
transforme des accidents qui sont des
accidents mortels en des accidents qui
sont des accidents corporels et où voilà
à un piéton la différence entre un
piéton à 50 km/h à un piéton à 30 km/h
c'est la différence entre un tuer sur la
route et
quelqu'un qui qui malheureusement va
être blessé mais va se remettre de cet
accident alors le trophée que je voulais
aborder avec vous je suis des
trottinettes électriques il y a eu 600
blessés graves en France en 2022 34 trop
de citer trottinettiste qui sont décédés
en 2022 il y a l'Académie de médecine
notamment qui demande une réglementation
plus stricte en la matière est-ce que
vous êtes du même avis pour aller
justement vers moins d'accidents alors
nous au sein de l'association d'un
conseil médical qui qui a étudié cette
question et qui nous a fait remonter
aussi un certain nombre d'informations
que des différents hôpitaux et ce qui
nous dit c'est que aujourd'hui on se on
a de plus en plus de traumatismes
crâniens et de d'écrasement de la face
du au trottinettes électriques c'est ça
s'explique par cet engin car un engin ou
le centre de gravité est très bas et on
fait très facilement un soleil quand on
a une aspérité sur la route quand on
rencontre un obstacle et donc c'est la
phase qui prend qui est souvent parce
qu'on n'a pas le réflexe de forcément de
mettre les mains et de
qui sont occupés par le guidon et donc
de ce de se protéger nous
le développement de la trottinette
électrique qu'on a c'est une mesure
qu'on a porté à l'occasion des
présidentielles on a toujours défendu le
fait qu'il fallait obliger les personnes
qui utilisent cette trottinette
électrique apporter un casque et même ce
qu'on nous c'est que
au-delà du casque il y a ces espèces de
casque intégraux là qui protège aussi la
face parce que et la mâchoire parce
qu'on a des des traumatismes sur sur la
mâchoire donc on a réglementé on sait
maintenant où doit se rouler les
trottinettes électriques toutes ces
zones de flou dans au début sur le
développement de la trottinette
électrique on sait maintenant où elles
doivent rouler je pense que il faut
maintenant agir sur sur l'usager que je
le disais tout à l'heure c'est les
usagers vulnérables ils ont pas de
carrosserie c'est
et c'est voilà il faut il faut prendre
des mesures pour pour les personnes qui
utilisent la trottinette et il faut
qu'on fasse rentrer la trottinette
électrique comme un véritable mode de
déplacement parce que
je pense qu'il y a encore un côté
utilisation un peu fun de la trottinette
électrique et montage sensibiliser c'est
aussi le rôle on l'a compris de votre
association et de faire un travail
auprès aussi des pouvoirs publics pour
pouvoir peut-être
on porte ça on l'a porté pendant les
présidentielles on est
et on met en place des actions de
prévention sur la trottinette électrique
sur
sur des entreprises qui s'équipent
aujourd'hui de trottinette électrique
mais qui veulent que leur salarié une
sensibilisation avant et on avait un
programme
c2eux c'est appelé mobiprox qui qui
faisait de la sensibilisation sur la
trottinette électrique très rapidement
leur rôle est essentiel sur la
prévention il y a aussi le rôle que
peuvent jouer les collectivités qui
décident de déployer ce type de service
parce qu'il y a effectivement la loi
mais nous on a décidé d'aller beaucoup
plus loin je rappelle que sur
Saint-Quentin on a des engins dont la
vitesse est bridée à 20 km/h qu'on a
exigé dans notre appel à candidature qui
a un casque intégré aux trottinette donc
tout ça ce sont des choses que les
collectivités peuvent décider notre
trottinette sont également immatriculés
donc il y a aussi un élan en termes de
sécurité à donner quand on souhaite
lancer ce type de projet merci en tout
cas d'être venu parler de ce sujet je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
régional d'Île-de-France Île-de-France
de l'association Prévention Routière
avant de parler de la situation des
avocats dans l'actualité également il y
a ce projet qui commence à avoir le jour
du côté de la ville de Maurepas c'est
une première microforêt
urbaine qui a été planté au Square de
l'Estérel sur une ancienne
station-service c'est une plantation qui
s'est voulu participative avec les
habitants qui sont venus en nombre
samedi pour prêter main forte on regarde
tout de suite le reportage de Céline
Charles et de Julien Leroy enfiler des
gants prenez une pioche et ajoutez
beaucoup de motivation vous obtenez le
cocktail parfait pour la création d'une
microforée au quartier de la Giot à
Maurepas les habitants ont été invités à
planter 1900 arbrés arbustes sur 650
mètres carrés
comme ça tu peux creuser à on a on a
creusé ensuite on a essayé d'un peu de
on a mis la plante on a remis un peu de
terre et on a ramolli la terre et on a
mis une espèce de petit copeau de bois
autour au total 250 personnes ont
répondu présentes sur la journée une
manière pour les habitants de contribuer
à la vie de leur quartier tout en
faisant un geste pour l'environnement on
a un peu d'estime en se disant on va on
va aider à notre échelle à planter des
arbres même si c'est pas grand chose
c'est c'est toujours mieux que que de ne
rien faire pour nous c'est surtout
investir dans notre quartier un endroit
un peu plus beau pour nos balades
quotidiens et pour les plus petits
d'être sensibilisés dès leur plus jeune
âge pour que dans 20 ans il est plus
d'arbres et que
ce soit plus écologique c'est la vraie
des animaux
ça freine le réchauffement climatique
mon repas est la deuxième ville de 50
ans en Yvelines à s'engager dans cette
démarche après plaisir objectif à terme
recréer un microsystème dans un milieu
urbain l'objectif c'est de créer des
îlots de fraîcheur à terme cette
microforêt va favoriser justement la
biodiversité d'ici 3 à 5 ans et cette
microfora et après sera impénétrable
d'ici une vingtaine d'années rendez-vous
dans quelques années pour les premiers
résultats la ville est déjà à la
recherche d'un second site pour y
implanter une nouvelle microforée la
suite du sétudes avec cette question
comment se porte la profession des
avocats on a posé tout de suite ouais on
a va poser on a posé tout à l'heure la
question on va la reposer à Geoffrey
Meyer qui est avocat au Barreau de
Versailles qui est avec nous également
ancien secrétaire de la Conférence du
stage alors en votre lieu est place il y
avait il y a 15 jours Maryvonne
Caillebotte qui est la procureur de la
République de Versailles qui nous
parlait de ce moment un peu difficile de
la justice avec ses procédures qui
augmentent j'ai envie de aussi démarrer
cet entretien avec vous avec une la
première question quelle est à votre
avis le plus grand problème que
rencontre les justiciables et par voie
de conséquences aussi les avocats en
réalité la question la réponse que je
vais formuler à votre question elle
pourrait ressembler à celle que vous a
formulées madame la procureur de la
République il y a 15 jours lorsque vous
l'avez interrogé c'est globalement le
manque de moyens de la justice puisque
en réalité les justiciables ils
attendent des réponses concrètes et
rapides lorsque ils interrogent la
justice sur leur problématiques et en
raison de ce manque de moyens de ce
manque de juge l'art principal
difficulté je pense c'est de pas avoir
ses réponses satisfaisantes dans un
délai suffisamment rapide on peut parler
de surmenage aujourd'hui c'est un terme
qui est approprié ah oui tout à fait
tout à fait on a une vraie problématique
par rapport à cela qui est que la
justice ne rend pas des décisions dans
un délai qui est d'acceptable et c'est à
la fois la problématique je vous le
disais du justicable et des avocats
c'est globalement l'accès au juge qui
sont en nombre nettement insuffisant
alors l'année 2023 va être celle de la
généralisation des cours criminels qui
sont censés justement rendre les
jugements en matière pénale plus rapide
en prenant aussi par des affaires qui
étaient jugés devant les cours d'assises
est-ce que déjà vous pouvez nous
rappeler ce que sont les cours criminels
et qu'est-ce que vous pensez également
de cette mise en place alors les cours
criminels se sont des cours qui sont
censés juger des crimes qui sont punis
de 15 à 20 années de prison et pour
lesquelles les auteurs ne sont pas en
état de récidive légale
ils sont composés de 5 magistrats
professionnels ou
par exception des avocats honoraires qui
peuvent exercer de manière
exceptionnelle cette fonction-là ou des
magistrats à titre temporaire mais il
n'y a plus comme dans les cours
d'assises de jury populaire il n'y a que
des magistrats au sein des cours
criminels départementales voilà donc
c'est effectivement une spécificité on
est sur une juridiction qui vient
s'intercaler entre le tribunal
correctionnel et la cour d'assise pour
ses crimes spécifiques punies de 15 à 20
années de prison qu'est-ce que vous
pensez justement de la généralisation en
2023 de quoi on rappelle d'ailleurs que
l'actuel garde des sceaux Eric
Dupont-Moretti quand il était avocat
était farouchement opposé alors que
c'est lui aujourd'hui qui est à
l'origine de cette mesure c'est quoi
criminel départemental elle pose à mon
avis un certain nombre de difficultés
déjà ça ne devait être qu'une
expérimentation et le garde des sceaux
n'a pas eu la sagesse de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui a attendu
de voir si la trottinette marchait pour
pouvoir la généraliser il a décidé et
que les cours criminels départementales
une fois la phase d'expérimentation
terminée allez devenir général donc
s'étendre à tout le territoire qu'est-ce
qu'elle pose comme difficulté la
première c'est premièrement l'accès à la
justice par le citoyen on voit bien dans
le traitement médiatique de certaines
affaires et la réaction que peuvent
avoir les justiciables par rapport à
certaines situations que il y a une
vraie difficulté d'accès du citoyen à la
justice et c'était appréciable d'avoir
un jury populaire parce que justement
c'était le moment où le citoyen avait
accès directement à la justice ça pose
aussi une question et ça rejoint un
petit peu le propos que je vous tenais
précédemment
deux l'occupation des juges vous allez
avoir des cours criminels qui vont
mobiliser sac magistrat
bon les magistrats s'ils sont ils seront
pas plus nombreux une fois que les cours
criminels départementales sont arrivés
que avant que la cour criminelle
départementale le soit là donc ils vont
devoir délaisser les affaires qu'ils
avaient à juger pour justement s'occuper
de la cour criminelle de porte-manteale
et ça ça pose une difficulté généraliser
la cour criminelle départementale à la
limite pourquoi pas mais à ce moment-là
il aurait fallu envisager qu'il y ait
davantage de magistrats pour pouvoir
justement s'occuper de ses cours
criminels départementales je vous donne
un exemple il y a un barreau du centre
de la France dans lequel les tribus de
police ne vont plus pouvoir statuer sur
les affaires parce que les magistrats
qui sont justement chargés du jugement
de ces infractions notamment les
infractions routières et bien et bien
seront occupés à la cour criminelle
départementale donc vous voyez quand en
réalité ça pose vraiment une difficulté
et dernière peut-être difficulté un peu
plus à la marge que les autres ça va un
petit peu réduire aussi la nécessaire
des débats que
justifier la cour d'assise la cour
d'assise est un moment où vraiment on
prenait le temps mettez des dossiers à
plat les enjeux étaient importants on
était effectivement sur des peines
supérieures à des années
d'emprisonnement donc ça valait la peine
juste franc qu'on prenne le temps la
cour criminelle sans doute aura vocation
à traiter ses affaires de manière plus
rapide et ça c'est au détriment quand
même des personnes qui sont à la fois
accusées et aussi des victimes et je
pense que c'est regrettable et c'est en
tout cas la position de la profession
d'avocat concernant ce déploiement des
cours criminels départements on a
compris vos réserver l'année dernière
question on peut penser que les citoyens
qui sont pas habitués peut-être à venir
vers les avocats qui peuvent ressentir
une certaine appréhension à pousser la
porte d'un cabinet ça peut être un
timidant un avocat quels sont les bonnes
raisons les bonnes raisons d'y avoir
recours et est-ce que ça coûte cher
aujourd'hui alors
déjà il faut que les justiciables et on
comprend parfaitement leurs inquiétudes
quant à l'existence des cabinets
d'avocats sont à la façon dont cela
fonctionne et à la façon dont ils vont
être traités notamment sur le plan
déshonoraires depuis 2015 est-ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que la convention
d'honoraires est obligatoire
c'est-à-dire que les avocats doivent
faire signer ou justiciables dont la
charge des intérêts une convention qui
va lister l'intégralité des diligences
qu'ils vont effectuer pour eux et le
coût prévisible de la procédure donc là
dessus on peut comprendre bien
évidemment que les justiciables et une
inquiétude par rapport à cela mais
depuis 2015 c'est encadré il existe
aussi des dispositifs qui fonctionnent
très bien de prise en charge des
honoraires au titre de l'aide
juridictionnelle c'est à dire par l'État
pour les justiciables qui n'auraient pas
les moyens justement de faire appel à un
avocat et pourquoi faire appel à un
avocat parce que alors parce qu'un
avocat c'est plus qu'utile c'est
indispensable l'un avocat c'est un
professionnel qui va vous orienter dans
vos choix procédureaux et qui va vous
guider pour justement maximiser la
défense de vos intérêts
un avocat c'est quelqu'un qui connaît
les lois et la procédure et je suis
intimement persuadé que un avocat
lorsque on doit faire valoir ses droits
d'une quelconque façon c'est
indispensable véritablement un avocat ce
n'est jamais quelque chose de superflu
il vaut mieux pousser la porte d'un
cabinet d'avocat pour justement faire
valoir ses intérêts que de risquer de
justement les défendre tout seul la
casse est toujours supérieure lorsqu'on
se trompe tout seul que lorsqu'on fait
appel à un avocat qui peut justement
vous orienter en amont sur la nécessité
et l'utilité de tel ou tel procédure
merci d'être venu le dire sur le plateau
de TV 78 Geoffrey meilleur je rappelle
que vous êtes avocat au Barreau de
Versailles allez c'est l'heure d'ouvrir
une page culturelle dans ce 7 8
[Musique]
breakdance français avait rendez-vous le
week-end dernier à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse avec la
première phase de qualification et du
Red Bull bicyone une centaine de big
girls et de bboy se sont affrontés sur
des enflammés de DJ looni pour
accéder à la finale nationale qui aura
lieu à Montpellier retour sur cet
événement avec Mathilde de Franco et
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
[Musique]
un contrat sur la piste le Red Bull
bicyone est l'un des plus grands
championnats du breaking du monde et il
faisait étape à Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse
une centaine de bboys et big girl se
sont affrontés en duel pour une place en
finale nationale le 9 juillet prochain
la révolution
pour la plupart des gens qui dansent
vrai du coup c'est bien important ça
fait 12 ans que
ça fait la troisième fois que je
participe à la compétition pour moi le
niveau français c'est vraiment très très
fort je considère entre pays plus fort
du monde les breakdance
il y a 13 ans cette danse et pourtant
originaire des États-Unis et elle
mélange coin sportive et figure
artistiques il y a pas de figure imposée
c'est moi personnellement juge sur
beaucoup sur la musicalité et
l'originalité les mouvements signatures
la patte des danseurs danseuses c'est DJ
qui qui choisit la musique et personne
ne sait ce alors forcément il y a des
musiques que les bboys et big girls
connaissent sur lesquels ils sont
entraînés donc voilà mais aucun danseur
danseuse ne choisit la musique parmi les
qualifiés pour la finale nationale le
bboy PAC pack c'est un habitué
[Musique]
j'ai gagné trois fois le championnat de
France du coup pour moi c'est la routine
c'est la routine ne dis pas que c'est la
routine mais je veux dire c'est que ça
je l'ai gagné trois fois d'accord et moi
mon but c'est de revenir au top de mon
niveau pour aller à l'international en
France je sais ce que je veux j'ai pas
besoin la finale internationale aura
lieu le 21 octobre à Roland-Garros un
bon entraînement avant les Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 ou le
breakdance fera son entrée pour la
première fois dans un instant les
insolites de Véronique Ithurbide qui m'a
rejoint au plateau bonsoir Véronique
pour voir les informations qui nous ont
peut-être échappé sur le territoire des
Yvelines on va parler de ces
informations insolites on parlait de
bachata semaine dernière breakdance vous
êtes plutôt preneuse vous aimez bien le
breakdance on en parle bien sûr
breakdance oui mais ce n'est plus du
tout de d'actualité mon pauvre Grégory
on parle d'autre chose que de breakdance
tout à l'heure dans vos informations
insolites mais juste avant de la musique
avec le weekend dernier hein cet
événement qui était qui prenait place du
côté de la Maison de l'Environnement de
Manille les hameau c'est le tremplin des
voix saison 8 21 candidats étaient en
lice pour ce concours de chant à la clé
du matériel de musique des rencontres
avec des professionnels et des
enregistrements en studio alors parmi
les lauréats de cette édition on
retrouve Clémentine qui remporte la
première place dans la catégorie 17 ans
et moins les 11 gagnent le prix auteur
compositeur et interprète et enfin Soul
a été distingué dans la catégorie 18 ans
et plus avec son titre colors l'artiste
7 juge même le prix du public voici
quelques extraits des prestations des
vainqueurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier prix
du public
[Applaudissements]
cet événement s'ouvre lui ce soir la
deuxième édition du Festival du film
francophone pour la jeunesse et du 14 au
21 février au cinéma Frédéric Dard c'est
au Mureaux et pour en parler nous avons
un invité en visioconférence et Sylvain
Garrel bonsoir
bonsoir et le directeur artistique de ce
festival qui revient donc pour une
deuxième édition justement pourquoi le
reposer la première édition avait été un
succès
non la première édition je le
reconnaître pas grand monde mais on
sortait juste du covid et comme vous le
savez le cinéma a connu quelques mois
difficiles depuis l'année 2022 et donc
voilà c'est un festival annuel on sait
pas découragé on a repris mon patron de
pèlerin et cette année en vue des
réservations et de la première séance
qui a déjà eu lieu cet après-midi à 14h
il y avait beaucoup de monde je pense
qu'on sera là dans un vrai festival la
première édition étant une préfiguration
de fait alors le principe du festival
tout est dans le titre un finalement
c'est projection de films venus du monde
entier mais avec un vecteur commun celui
de la langue française est aussi du film
pour la jeunesse c'est ça qui est mis en
avant dans ce festival
tout à fait alors en précisant que pour
nous la jeunesse c'est de 3 à 103 ans
vous voyez on a une vision très très
large de la jeunesse c'est il y a comme
le montre vos images quelques films
d'animation mais il y a des films tout à
fait pour aussi des personnes plus âgées
comme le film d'ouverture qu'on va
présenter ce soir on l'avant-première
l'astronaute avec Mathieu kassovis et
Hippolyte Girardot qui n'est pas
spécialement mais oui il y a des jeunes
c'est-à-dire que c'est plutôt cette
vision c'est montrer la jeunesse
francophone plutôt que c'est pas des
projections réservées aux jeunes avec
des films en sélection je crois qu'il y
en a 11 cette année il me semble pour
pour cette deuxième édition comment
sont-ils choisis justement c'est une
c'est vous qui avez fait le choix de ses
films en sélection
alors j'ai essayé d'être le plus
éclectique possible à la fois dans les
origines et dans les
types de films les origines donc on a
cette année 13 métrages originaire de 12
pays différents du cadre continent à peu
près toute la zone francophone et puis
les films très différents dans le type
de public qui peut toucher au quotidien
à ce dernier Astérix
que des films beaucoup plus rares comme
par exemple le club Finland infime
québécois qui est qui n'a jamais diffusé
en France ou Auria un film Algérien qui
sera présenté samedi soir en
avant-première ou un film comme qui
vient du Sénégal et du palais qui a été
présenté en France pendant quelques
semaines et pas du tout dans les
Yvelines et donc voilà c'est on veut
présenter à la fois des films tout à
fait grand public et les films beaucoup
plus rares donc ça sera pour les gens
qui vous tiendront cette semaine au
sur un grand écran mais on fume plus
deux avant-première vous en avez parlé
tout à l'heure il y a l'astronaute de
Nicolas Giraud également ou rien dont
vous avez parlé de Mounia Medou et à
côté de ces projections également des
animations annexes il y a des ateliers
également inédits qui sont proposés
durant durant cette cet événement
exactement il y a des ateliers alors une
partie sont réservées au scolaires et au
centre de loisirs mais aussi samedi
après-midi ouvert à tous vous avez été
de montage de réalisation de pour
expliquer aux jeunes comment on fabrique
un film et puis il y a aussi un concours
de court-métrage là aussi qui est
réservé aux jeunes amateurs de cinéma
qui vont réaliser donc en quelques jours
pendant la durée du festival
des films de 2-3 minutes sur un thème
qui va leur être donné et il y a des
prix pour ceux qui vont réussir les
meilleurs
court-métrages pendant cette semaine le
tarif c'est 10 euros pour quatre pro
[Musique]
le film mais si vous achetez une carte
de 4 pour 4 films c'est 10 euros ce qui
est vraiment un prix tout à fait tout à
fait raisonnable pour aller au cinéma
moi j'habite Paris et le cinéma qui est
à côté de chez moi la place est à 14 €.
donc voyez là la grande différence et le
cinéma Frédéric Dard est un cinéma qui
est vraiment des calibrant une bonne
très bonne qualité de projection de des
fauteuils qui ont été refaits etc donc
c'est vraiment de très bonne condition
que dans les deux salles du cinéma
Frédéric Dard vous allez pouvoir voir
ses films donc ces films qui seront
proposés à l'occasion de la deuxième
édition du Festival du film francophone
pour la jeunesse donc c'est au Mureaux
on va revoir toutes les informations
s'afficher du 14 au 21 février au cinéma
Frédéric Dard toute la programmation
toutes les informations à retrouver sur
le site des Mureaux les mureaux.fr merci
Sylvain Gary d'avoir été avec nous
venez au festival oui très bon festival
c'est ce que j'allais vous souhaiter et
peut-être qu'on aura l'occasion de
passer pour pour TV 78 du cinéma on va
passer à la littérature et demande son
forcément liées est-ce qu'il y a un
livre qui vous a marqué jeune vous
Véronique Jeanne mon Dieu plein je me
souviens pas j'arrive pas à choisir mais
en tout cas qui vous ont donné peut-être
le goût de la lecture
puisque promouvoir la lecture chez les
jeunes c'est l'objectif de cette
opération qui se nomme livre à 1 euro
samedi dernier c'est l'enseigne cultura
des Clayes-sous-Bois qui participaient
en partenariat avec l'association Lire
c'est partir dans les bacs des romans
d'aventure ou encore des albums jeunesse
qui était proposés en tout
13189 livres ont été vendus sur la
journée on écoute le directeur du
magasin et quelques clients interrogés
par Julien Leroy nous notre intérêt
c'est de rendre accessible la culture
par notamment du coup le prix et donc
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on propose des
livres neufs à 1 euro pour permettre aux
personnes
de voyager on est très contents on a eu
beaucoup de monde ce matin on est
jusqu'à deux heures de temps d'attente
je trouve que c'est sympa ouais et puis
même pour les jeunes maintenant ils
vivent plus beaucoup ils sont tous sur
les écrans tout ça et je trouve que ça
peut apporter
leur apprendre à relire des livres même
si l'enfant ne s'intéresse pas ça nous
permet quand même de les avoir eu à 1
euro et puis après pouvoir les les
transmettre aux autres ou même de les
donner à des assos par la suite je sais
que vous attendez ce rendez-vous avec
impatience c'est l'heure des insolites
de Véronique dans le 7 8
et on va commencer Véronique avec une
invention assez écolo finit en effet les
gobelets en plastique un yvelinois a
inventé quelque chose de très astucieux
des tasses à croquer et c'est quoi cette
très concrètement il est pas tout seul
il est avec son épouse Julie voilà ils
sont deux en voilà elle elle vient du
monde du cadeau elle a une boutique de
de des cadeaux et lui a travaillé
longtemps dans l'événementiel donc il a
été à même de de constater le le nombre
de déchets que produisait n'importe quoi
un cocktail enfin une réception etc et
donc ils ont eu ensemble cette idée de
donc de s'associer pour ce projet qui a
du sens donc zéro déchet avec cette
tasse qui est constituée d'un biscuit
sec peu sucré je vois vos yeux vous êtes
en train de regarder
une épaisse couche de chocolat noir à
64% à l'intérieur et du coup ça sert de
contenant
voilà mais j'ai envie de vous dire
est-ce que ça fond pas du coup avec le
la boisson chaude ça ne fond pas
pourquoi parce que la résistance est
beaucoup plus faible avec le la chaleur
et le chocolat que entre la porcelaine
par exemple et je crois que je suis en
train de me dire n'importe quoi bref ça
ne font pas parce que ça refroidit vite
voilà c'est pour te dire
ça ne font pas et ça ne fuit pas non
plus bon en tout cas cette invention
100% est vinoise on pourra en parler et
puisqu'on va on va consacrer un
reportage sur sur cette invention des
recettes salées et du glaçage mystérieux
qui sont en train de mettre au point
pour que ça ne fût pas pendant qu'on
puisse mettre des soupes même dedans un
sucrés etc voilà c'est pour mars 23 les
autres recettes ça nous a donné en tout
cas enfin on passe à un autre sujet
alors qui est assez inquiétant
d'ailleurs mais qui mérite toute notre
attention c'est celui de l'agribashing
c'est quoi la gribashing alors la
coaching en fait c'est un terme qui est
apparu dans les années 2016 et c'est une
sorte de mouvement de critique contre le
mode de production des agriculteurs
intensifs l'agriculture intensive voilà
c'était pour critiquer ça sauf que très
vite ça s'est étendu un peu à tout le
monde agricole en fait on a dénigré
systématiquement enfin certaines
personnes ont dénigré systématiquement
les agriculteurs et les résultats ils
sont ils sont probants ils sont là il y
a beaucoup de monde vaches dans les
campagnes les agriculteurs sont
découragés et sont pas sans pas
valoriser et donc voilà c'est ça vient
des des antispécistes à la base enfin
entre autres les antispécistes vous qui
ne veulent pas qui pour pour eux
l'espèce humaine et à égalité avec
l'espèce animale voilà
souvent d'actualité et notamment à
l'approche du salon de l'agriculture
d'ailleurs dernier exemple en date sur
l'agribashing ça se passe du côté de la
ville d'Adainville de la commune
d'Adainville qui se situe bien sûr dans
les Yvelines ou un agriculteur rencontre
toute une série de problèmes avec ses
voisins racontez-nous alors en fait oui
c'est un couple un jeune couple qui
décide de s'installer à Adainville donc
charmante petit village pour créer un
élevage de 30 chevaux et de 15 vaches un
élevage bio 15 vaches de la race
pin-noir qui est une race de vache en
voie d'extinction une race bretonne
voilà donc tout va très bien sauf qu'en
2020 trois couples de leurs voisins se
mettent en tête de d'arrêter leurs
projets et imagine des nuisances et vont
donc en justice il y a un décret qui
leur donne raison mais ils vont de
recours en recours c'est c'est plaignant
donc ça bloque le projet ça avait donc
trois ans et enfin la justice l'a rendu
son verdict donc ils ont tout à fait le
droit de de créer leur élevage et il
commence déjà à amener leurs animaux sur
place etc parce qu'ils ont dû être
hébergé après avant pardon chez d'autres
personnes et là on en reparle pourquoi
parce que malgré le fait que la justice
donc le parquet de Versailles leur est
donné complètement le droit de monter
leur élevage et bien c'est ses voisins
ont l'auront écrit une lettre anonyme
ici nos voisins et ce sont permis le
plus tranquillement du monde de rentrer
chez eux et de déposer la lettre anonyme
dans sur la table de la salle à manger
des agriculteurs
divulguée sur sur Twitter également
voilà faut savoir que le maire
d'Adainville ne défend complètement ses
jeunes agriculteurs et que faut pas
mettre tous les habitants du village
dans le même panier mais le problème de
de ce stagri machine c'est que ça
décourage et de moins en moins d'élevage
de petits élevages on va on manque de
vache en France on va devoir importer
des des bêtes de très loin donc le
circuit court la qualité la traçabilité
tout ça bah il va falloir oublier très
vite parce que on va continuer à
consommer de la viande elle viendra de
du Brésil par exemple ça semblait pas
mal de choses en question et forcément
le sujet je pense reviendra encore une
fois sur la table avec le salon de l'A
voiture qui va s'ouvrir fin février à
Paris merci Véronique on vous retrouve
la semaine prochaine avec plaisir
nouvelle vidéo insolite
[Musique]
est-ce que vous voulez connaître le menu
de ce soir pour la Saint-Valentin en
équipe le menu chez vous oui c'est moi
qui cuisine pour la Saint-Valentin
et c'est ce soir le chef Maury maudit
maudit Sakho a du restaurant Les 4
Saisons c'est à Versailles qui propose
la recette pour l'astuce du chef
[Musique]
bienvenue au restaurant Les Quatre
Saisons à Versailles mais c'est ça comme
on dit sur les chefs
alors aujourd'hui on va vous parler de
risques de cœur de ris de veau pour
aller
forestière champignon pomme de terre et
quelques feuilles des herbes
[Musique]
il y a une petite astuce à retenir sur
les ris de veau et qui sont des ris de
veau c'est surtout les démarrer à l'eau
tiède et avec avec ça on met un tout
petit peu de gros sel et aussi pendant
les fers revenir quand on voit le faire
revenir dans les poils il faut aller
dans
une cuillère la piller pour enlever tout
ce qui a de l'eau en tailleur pour que
ça soit bien caramélisé les risques et
voilà
[Musique]
j'ai pris une bonne note de tous les
conseils merci à maudit Sakho pour cette
astuce du sel astuce du chef j'en perds
mon latin avant de se quitter un dernier
coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
et ce sera un ciel voilé demain matin
sur tout le territoire des Yvelines avec
même du brouillard peut-être le matin
côté température il fera 1 degré à
Mantes-la-Jolie de degrés dans le Centre
et Sud et du département dans
l'après-midi même condition mais un
thermomètre qui grimpe il fera 10 degrés
à Rambouillet Versailles à Houdan et
Mantes-la-Jolie et ce mercredi 15
février nous fêtons les clodes voilà
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de votre
fidélité demain vous retrouverez
Mathilde Franco aux commandes du nouvel
édition belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]